an den befehl stone müssen sich alle
erst mal gewöhnen tag eins bei der
bundeswehr auch für die 18 jährige lea
sie ist eine von sieben rekrutinnen die
die bundeswehr für ihre neue youtube
serie mit der kamera begleitet hat bei
der vorstellung im
verteidigungsministerium haben die
jungen frauen ihre dreimonatige
grundausbildung gerade hinter sich
soldat oder soldatin das macht für sie
keinen unterschied mehr soldat es eben
soldat und ich bin nicht jemand der sagt
ich mir soldaten genannt werden wir
machen die gleichen stuben sauber den
gleichen tagesablauf wir machen den
gleichen sport machen die gleichen tests
wir lernen das gleiche da ist kein
unterschied weil wir letztendlich alle
die gleiche uniform tragen natürlich
kommen in der serie auch die bundeswehr
klassiker wieder zur aufführung zum
beispiel wie baue ich mein bett
faltenfrei ich höre sie ist das vorbild
der kameraden ab
[Musik]
das jahr ist am besten raus 66 nach dem
ende der wehrpflicht hat die truppe ein
personalproblem der auftrag der filmchen
ist deshalb klar den dringend benötigten
nachwuchs ran holen und vorurteile
abbauen über die männerdomäne bundeswehr
mittlerweile sind fast 20 prozent der
gesamten bundeswehr weiblich und bei
militärischen personals sind das über
22.000 300 frauen und wir möchten gerne
andere junge frauen ermuntern zu uns zu
kommen
7 millionen euro lässt sich die
bundeswehr die webserie mit 63
folgenkosten der look ein einziges run
wanzen an die zielgruppe nix mit
hochglanz alles soll unbefristet sein
es wackelt eben youtube die stärke der
serie ist ja auch dass die rekruten
eigentlich die kameras ganz schnell
vergessen denn uns geht es um die
authenzität wir wollen die
grundausbildung so zeigen wie sie
wirklich ist und dass vor allem
ungeschminkt jede der rekrutinnen hat
mindestens einen moment in dem sie alles
hinschmeißen will die quälenden
sporttest das frühe aufstehen das magere
essen geschönt wird nichts
lea wechselt übrigens demnächst zur
offiziersschule und will notfalls auch
in den auslandseinsatz
ich denke frauen sind absolut gebraucht
in den streitkräften weil was wir
vielleicht nicht an muskelkraft haben
haben wir davon gehört